je n'ai jamais passé à la télévision
c'est vraiment sans premier passage
alors il a un petit peu le trac je vous
le dis comme ça en passant il est né il
ya vingt ans à paris c'est un gavroche
vous n'avez qu'à écouter l'accent
regarder la case crête et vous aurez
tout de suite compris il a également une
politique tout à fait particulière c'est
la sienne
jugez plutôt d'après le titre de sa
chanson camarades bourgeois vous voulez
en savoir plus à leur écoute et le
maintenant renault
[Musique]
trion pharma de ses doigts le petit
chèque enfin
[Musique]
sap a pas vraiment
a l'air con quand tu sors le dimanche
ton petit complet veston et ta chemise
blanche car toi
regarde toi là
gama
la camarade fils à papa tu roule en
ferrari ou en lamborghini tu roule des
épaules toutefois super drôle regarde
toi
regarde toi
[Musique]
c'est ton père et patron faut pas en
faire un complexe
le jour de la révolution en lui ou
braque la tête
regarde toi
artois
cannes
notre fils à papa tu passes ton temps
drogue store ou sur les champs elysées
tu te crois très très forte jamais qu'un
minéraux
toi
regarde toi
[Musique]
l'acama
rejoint les rangs de l'as fait quand tu
prendras vraiment inquiet ne soit plus
une cote qui pèsent
s'était défoncés
moi pas
regarde moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]